[Music]
how do you process this sexiest man
alive thing is it something that you're
you're comfortable with does it make you
uncomfortable I mean share what it's
like makes me comfortable and
uncomfortable at the same time right
right it's bizarre and funny and awesome
and cool woman yeah who doesn't harbor
some like secret desire to kind of want
that a little bit here's a question I
have there are some people who they sort
of come into full blossom and people
think they're really sexy but when they
were younger they didn't feel that way
about themselves they weren't confident
what were you like when you were like
around highschool age it's kind of
reversed actually now I'm a lot less
confident I was delusional II like
unreasonably confident when I was really
well not when I was in like you know
freshman high school that's a disaster
for everybody yeah but I got a little
bit you know let 10th 11th 12th grade I
was it was like I was a jerk you know
this is kind of I was really an into
myself you know and yeah nothing's
changed not but I'm not the same way
that I was I had this weird confidence
that was just kind of bizarre so you
would walk around I think we have a
picture of you from this arrow here you
are so you would walk around and just
say I'm it I mean ladies line up cuz
here I am like of course I mean look at
that look at that goober in the
photograph I mean yes that's sexy cheese
yeah you bet huh
you got the chain around your neck that
was I believe that was actually uh a
beaded necklace I believe it was the
beet it wasn't a chain type Wow
was that OH was it like a puka shell
necklace yeah I'm not even that cool it
was like some beads it like some girl
gave it to me when I was excited about
it that's nice
I never had anything like that when I
was that age was a friendship necklace
yeah I don't know what are we even
talking about the necklace I don't know
I had a My Little Pony scarf that I wore
don't tell in my early 30s